[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt kreislauf erkrankungen sind die
häufigsten todesursachen in der
westlichen welt dachte das wird jetzt
ein telefonat von bio jaja moment da
bekommen wir gleich jeden fall neben
genetischen faktoren steigt das risiko
für herz kreislauf erkrankungen durch
schlechte ernährung einen mangel an
bewegung und rauchen doch ein faktor der
gerne übersehen liebt ist stress die
deutschen haben den ruf besonders
fleißig um effizient zu sein dabei ist
deutschland was die urlaubstage pro jahr
betrifft mit durchschnittlich 27 tagen
weltweit ziemlich weit vorne mit dabei
und das ist gut so denn stress
überstunden und die unfähigkeit in der
freizeit von der arbeit abzuschalten
wirklich nur körperlich ungesund sondern
verschlechtern auch engagement
motivation der arbeitnehmer
das wurde jetzt wahrscheinlich niemanden
aber es ist trotzdem gut zu wissen dass
mehrere dutzend studie weltweit
wissenschaftlich belegen dass urlaub
gesund unter anderem was man folgende
zusammenhänge menschen die über jahre
mehr als acht stunden pro tag arbeiten
haben eine bis zu 50 prozent erhöhte
wahrscheinlichkeit für eine koronare
herzerkrankung also eine verhärtung der
herzkranzgefäße menschen die über jahre
hinweg einen kurzen urlaub nehmen
zeigen 31 erhöhte wahrscheinlichkeit für
einen herzinfarkt und die psychische
gesundheit die nicht direkt mit der
leistungsfähigkeit auf der arbeit
korreliert wurde in vier studien
untersucht durch urlaub können gefahr
für burnout oder depression verringert
und gucken libeskind nicht erhöht werden
allerdings wurde ebenfalls beobachtet
dass die positiven effekt wird nach dem
urlaub schnell wieder dem arbeitsalltag
weichen heißt dass man kann doch gleich
lassen mit dem urlaub um die psychologin
jessica die blumen zu zitieren
das wäre als würde man fragen warum
schlafen wie obwohl wir eben der müde
werden
mein fazit daraus ist wie schlafen und
viel urlaub zumindest versuche damit
liebe grüße auf italien
[Musik]
mehr